[Music]
there ain't no grave can hold my body
down there ain't no grave can hold my
body down good cold evening gentlemen
a musty inventory I've been led to
believe it's a specimen I'm keen to
acquire what's your name Django and
you're exactly the one I'm looking for
hey stop talking to him calm down I'm
simply a customer trying to conduct a
transaction last chance fancy pants oh
very well you know what about the
interior uqp
gonna give you a reward mmm better they
are bigger than reward I need your help
I'm looking for the brittle brothers
however I don't know what they look like
what do you do don't you pick on my wife
when they sold it but I don't know
that means we visit every plantation
until we find once a final burger
brother lies dead in the dust I agree to
give you your freedom and I'll take you
to rescue your wife we're going you had
my curiosity but now you have my
attention
[Music]
[Applause]
how do you like the bounty hunting
business
I like the way you die boy is the
[Applause]
government gave me a decoration major
Jay Gatsby for valor extraordinary
that's right
could it all be true Gatsby
he had an extraordinary sense of hope
but I had the uneasy feeling that he was
guarding secrets
gasps be I'd like to know who he is what
he does look at my boss mr. Carraway
there's my good friend mr. my wolf show
Allison look in for a business
connection happens be confidential
you understand I do I'm certainly glad
to see you again I think about you like
that to see you so
just run away I've just heard the most
shocking thing can't repeat the past can
repeat the past
[Applause]
[Applause]
I of course you can
[Music]
[Music]
to my right is bounty law series lead
and jake cahill himself rick dalton and
to my left is rick stunt double cliff
booth so Rick explain to the audience
exactly what it is a stunt double dutch
actors are required to do a lot of
dangerous stuff cliff here is meant to
help carry the load is that how you
describe your job cliff what carrying
his load it's about right
[Music]
[Music]
my hands are registered as lethal
weapons we get into a fight I
accidentally kill you I go to jail
anybody accidentally kills anybody in a
fight to go to jail it's called
manslaughter
[Music]
[Music]
that was the best thing I've ever seen
in my whole life thank you there's one
thing you should know about me I
specialize in a very specific type of
security subconscious security you're
talking about dreams
[Music]
mr. Cobb has a job offer he would like
to discuss with you Luke our work
placement
not exactly we create the world of the
dream
we bring the subject into that dream and
they fill it with their secrets then you
break in and steal it well it's not
strictly speaking legal
it's called inception
already
I think I found a way home
last job
that's how I get there
feel real while we're in them Zoe when
we wake up that we realize something was
actually strange
because your responsibilities they're
not prepared to us
[Music]
dreams collapsing
I have it under control
I'd hate to see out of control it
mustn't be afraid to dream with a bigger
down it and I was your age they would
say we could become cops or criminals
when you're facing a loaded gun what's
the difference this is not the regular
place this is the stay place we are in
elite unit it's a so we're after Frank
Costello you won't be paid as a regular
cop but there's a bonus involved so what
do I do
you will not ever know the identity of
undercover people you have anyone in
with Costello presently maybe Do You
Know Who I am
maybe not when I have my associates
search you that was quick
things dead already I think we could
work something left we are all convinced
the Costello has at least one mole
inside the Special Investigations Unit
there are part of my job I can't talk to
you about well you are trouble you don't
know the half of it
you better get organized quick hey last
time I checked I tipped you off and
you're not in jail
get the feeling we got a cop micro
sooner ladies gonna find out who I am
and he's gonna kill me
calm down we're the only two people on
the face of this earth that even know
you're a cop I can get the rat you just
gotta let me do it my way
if you don't it won't be me who pays for
it
you're lying to me there are things you
don't want to know about what are you
waiting for us I mean do you want her to
chop me up and feed me the poor is that
what you guys want
[Music]
[Music]
they say it came from the heart of the
earth to test the hearts of men a stunt
so rare men will do anything to possess
it Wars will be fought in search of it
and all who touch it are left with blood
on their hands
[Music]
so what are you smuggling no journalists
[Music]
you're gonna steal this time that
dommages lot ticketed
the only reason I'm still alive is
because you haven't told anyone wear it
it's stupid to me you're gonna show us
where it's hidden
never find itself we block this
where is my son
where it is my home
sometimes I wonder God never forgive us
for what we've done to each other and I
realized God left this place a long time
ago
[Music]
[Music]